[Music]
I don't know probably he's the guy to
ask is
that go
by you'd also know how to correctly
pronounce
no
was
out
e
okay hi
everyone
hi
everyone welcome to the
S I'm director of the Science
Institute we are collab Research
Institute and
we are dedicated for direct
science field we typically run two
programs each
semester 7 visitors Junior visitors
senior visitors Berkeley and each
including camp this is Camp and several
workshops that bring even more visitors
here
during uh this semester uh one of the
program is a CO here in practice and
this is for this program so welcome to
the program and I first want to thank
the organizers for organizing program
and ex set speakers for this week
already Mary
vard J and GOI and Henry I think
everybody here is except for go that
corre so um I'll hand it over to in a
minute and he'll the boot camp
specifically
but uh I guess in general when we have
boot camps here the goal is to have of
ice breaker for the program both
scientific and social they get everyone
on the same page of what there spectrum
of the program things are what they
important problems and the state of art
of F and then a year from now there's a
reunion usually for each program which
so says what has happened in this year
because often we have to Z these
programs is that you start collaborating
to start a work but all of that is
accomplished within later on although
don't want to tell you actually
accomplish something during the program
just saying that if you don't there
later on and in a reunion we usually see
a lot more things that would happen
during the semester and uh you'll also
be asked to uh update a research
report or write a during the reunion and
um and uh what else um just speaking the
director we're always looking for new
programs and new ideas of how to better
our collaborations so welcoming any
input from the participants terms of
logistics I guess you as you saw we have
snacks we have coffee we have uh food
during breaks but during lunch as you're
on your own and uh we hope you can enjoy
what we provide but not in in this
room so so in other words I hope you can
enjoy what provide but you're not
allowed to actually eat and drink in
this
room and masks uh this is but as you
know coming again so we recommend them
Al we don't require them the locker is
available the Wi-Fi is C or anywh those
who have counts 4:30 we're going have a
reception today where we some try to go
to people ince
U and we'll introduce the staff so we to
show up like 4:30 to 5:30 our
videographer today is
not
hi want totr
yourself I'm Sam Sam
you have a microphone right
there example so Sam will tell us when
we should use the microphone and um and
if you have any problems with your
slides or something Sam is is our
man and uh finally a big thanks to our
organizers to Ashley who's the event
coordinator and everybody else on the
team uh and uh they work for and really
have set up for all the local
arrangements for this meeting and this
event and feel free to ask Ashley and
her team if you have any questions I
think at this point I'm going to hand it
over to vad welcome to Simons thank
[Applause]
you good morning everyone uh my name is
wenar guruswami I'm a senior scientist
at Simon Institute and also a
co-organizer this program and on behalf
of all my co-organizers it's my great
pleasure to welcome you all to this
program we are all looking forward to a
really fun and productive time advancing
frontiers of eror correcting codes um as
Shafi said the boot camps are sort of
unique uh um in the Simon Institute
programming because they kind of really
get people up to speed very quickly on
Research Frontiers and they also have a
really long shelf life after this week
too they're you know those videos are
some of the most watched by worldwide by
graduate students researchers of all
seniority so so no pressure on the
speakers but uh you know this is a
really really valuable uh uh resource
and of course we try to um we're trying
to focus on some topics where there has
been a lot of action now coding Theory
by itself is a very broad field uh
bringing together math people
information theorists computer
scientists and also many different noise
models many different directions and
even focusing on directions where there
has been lots of progress in the last
five years there is still a big list so
with that all that in mind we have
curated a few topics where there are uh
some um interesting progress and also we
have a lot of local expertise so they
could uh you know Foster collaborations
things like algebraic codes locality
and given the strong Synergy we uh hope
and anticipate with the quantum parallel
Quantum program we have six hours of
quantum uh era correction uh in the boot
camp and we also have some other classic
topics like problemistic and
combinatorial methods polar coding and
so on and this by of course is by no
means exhaustive and uh they're already
on the zulip channel which you should
join if you haven't already there's lots
of ideas on reading groups on some other
topics like pseudo Randomness comes to
mind and other things so so there's
going to be lots of uh different threads
and this boot camp is an introduction to
a few of those um with that said I'll
just remind you about again the
reception today at 4:30 and I'll hand it
over to Mary who's our first uh speaker
and also we'll give a little more
details about some
Logistics thanks so much
vanot hi everybody uh yeah so before I
dive into the first technical talk I
have just a few logistical announcements
and things um so the see if
I so the first thing I want to say is
just reiterate thank you to the Simons
Institute um and its amazing staff for
helping make this program possible uh
both today's or this week's boot camp
and also just the whole semester I'm so
excited for the semester the staff here
is incredible it's thank you so much
this is amazing um a few quick
announcements uh so I think Shafi
mentioned that uh at some point we'll be
putting together sort of a report of all
of the things that happened during this
program uh it seems like it might be
helpful to start putting together that
report in real time rather than trying
to remember a year later what happened
so with that in mind we're looking for
volunteers to put together a report for
this Workshop so let me know if you're
interested you if you take good notes or
if you want an incentive to take good
notes this is an excellent time to do
that um so uh let me know um you can
just ping me uh in person or by email or
on zulip or whatever um and speaking of
zulip uh long-term visitors please sign
up for zulip if you haven't already you
should have gotten plenty of spam from
me uh in your email about how to sign up
let me know if you're still having
difficulties um great uh and one more
quick announcement um speed talks so you
might have noticed if you looked at the
boot camp program that we have uh two
chunks of speed talks one on Thursday
and one on Friday um and this is an
opportunity for all y'all to tell us
what you are excited about Um this can
be anything like open problems cool
results fun techniques uh or just an
introduction like hi my name is so and
so and here's a quick summary of what I
work on um and uh yeah so we we really
hope that this will be an opportunity to
get a little bit more beyond the topics
that we're you know talking about in the
boot camp to see you know to get a
chance to see what everyone's working on
and hopefully to form connections and
Foster collaboration um so please do
consider signing up for a a boot camp
you can um scan this QR code to uh
submit a link there's like just a Google
form or there's also a link on zulip and
in your email inbox and um I'll be
throwing this up again later um I just
realized I'm wearing a lapel mic I don't
need this
mic
just leave it and turn this one off is
this working good all right sweet cool
uh okay so yeah please uh submit a speed
talk um that'll be great okay and then I
just wanted to say uh one quick note
about um sort of the goals of the boot
camp and the structure of the boot camp
so as vcat mentioned um he sort of
talked a little bit about the topics
that we're going to cover but I want to
maybe go just one level higher than that
and mention sort of the ultimate goal of
the boot camp um so like ch said is sort
of to get everybody on the same page and
really to Foster collaboration because
we have so many different communities
here we have folks from CS math
engineering physics um all of these
things and you we want to be able to
work with each other and talk to each
other in the upcoming semester um and
our strategy for getting everyone on the
same page and giving everyone a common
language is focused on giving us all
sort of some common techniques and
problems so the idea is if I learn about
your shiny new Hammer your tool then I
might be like oh I have a nail for that
and like maybe we'll work together or if
I hear about your open problem your nail
I'll be like I think I've got a hammer
in my toolkit that I could like take a
swing at that with um and then maybe
we'll work together um so that the hope
is that you know by sort of focusing on
techniques and problems we'll find
points where we can sort of Leverage all
of our diverse strengths um so we've
asked the boot camp speakers to please
highlight these as they show up in their
talks I'm going to be doing it with
these silly little cartoons um so these
will show up uh repeatedly um my talk
and maybe some others as well okay so
keep an eye out for that and yeah always
be nice to sort of actively have in the
back of your head uh how like do I have
something in my toolkit that would
complement what what we're seeing this
great cool uh okay so with that out of
the way uh let me get started with the
actual talk which is um some algorithms
for some
algebraic okay so what does this talk
about um or these two talks actually
this one and then one after the break uh
so as the title suggests it's about
algebraic codes and some algorithms for
them um I was thinking about what to
talk about and okay there are a lot of
algebraic codes and there are a lot of
algorithmic things you might want to to
do with them I'm not going to read all
this stuff because the point is it is
too much so I am not going to be able to
unfortunately talk about all of algeb
codes and all the algorithms for them um
instead I'm going to focus a bit more
narrowly uh but hopefully uh the
trade-off will be that I'll have a
coherent talk um so for algebraic codes
I'm going to really just focus on read
Solomon code sort of the most classic
algebraic code um and then a few friends
um and algorithms for them I'm going to
be really focusing on just one
algorithmic Paradigm uh which I'll call
the interpolate A polinomial and find
some Roots Paradigm we'll see a few
examples of what this is um and of
course I'm necessarily going to emit a
lot of cool stuff about algebraic
algorithms or algebraic codes and
algorithms for them um if I omit
something that you really love that's a
great thing to speed talk about okay um
yeah so what's the plan um so there's
two talks in this first talk I'm going
to give three examples of this Paradigm
just so we sort of all understand what
it is um those three examples are bur
bamp wel algorithm the gam algorithm
algorith gaman Wang um not clear why I
am giving this talk instead of vott but
there we go um and then uh in the second
talk uh we're going to sort of build on
that framework and talk about
improvements that uh one can one can do
on this um including things like
leveraging locality distance
amplification and alphabet reduction so
this first talk oh and of course along
the way we'll highlight several open
problems um yeah so this first talk is
going to have more technical details
slightly more classical results all of
these are sort of at least 10 years old
the the goal here of this first talk is
really just to get us all on the same
page and teach us this Paradigm uh and
the second talk is going to be a little
bit more handwavy um I'm not going to go
into all the technical details just sort
of give you a flavor in the ideas um and
this will be more recent results and in
the second talk I'll really try to
emphasize like what is the state ofthe
art and and what are some big open
problems okay so that's the outline for
these two talks let's get started with
talk one um oh and I should say please
do stop me uh if you have any questions
I suspect I have more material than I
can cover something at the stop anyway
so there's we I want to go at a speed
that everyone can can follow um great
okay so talk one three examples of this
basic algorithmic Paradigm but first
terminology okay so um I'm just going to
sort of quickly set some terminology I'm
assuming that since y'all are here for a
program about error correcting codes
that most people here are familiar with
the basics of error correcting codes
that said like I said earlier we're all
coming from different communities we all
have different language so if I am
saying something that doesn't make sense
please do slow me down um but I am going
to go a little bit fast through through
this stuff okay so terminology so for me
a code is just a subset of a space Sigma
to the end so I'll draw it like this
this big blue blob here is Sigma to the
end and I'll draw my code AS points here
and these points I'm going to call code
words so these are vectors of length n
over the alphabet Sigma so I'll call
Sigma the alphabet and for this talk
this is a talk about algebraic code so
my alphabet is always going to be a
finite field fq or sometimes it'll be a
vector space over a finite field fq to
the S um and again talk about algebraic
codes so I'm going to be focusing on
linear codes uh in particular which
means that c is going to be an F Q
Subspace of Sigma to the end okay so so
far this is not a very interesting
definition a code is just a Subspace the
thing that makes a code interesting and
useful is its combinatorial properties
and sort of the most basic combinatorial
property of interest is distance so the
distance of a code is the minimum
Hamming distance between any two code
words I'm going to denote it Delta of C
so the minimum Hamming distance between
any two distinct Cod wordss um and here
I'm going always going to use Delta to
denote Hamming distance which is just
the number of position on which two
vectors differ and I'll use a lowercase
Delta to denote relative handing
distance which is the fraction of
coordinates on which two
vectors uh cool okay so why do we care
about distance well the the reason is
that we want our code to be able to do
error correction and so we imagine that
we're going to be using these code words
to transmit information um so the the
basic setup here is that the code words
are going to be injection with a set of
messages that live in sign DEC
and if we want to send some message
let's say this one uh what we're going
to do is we're going to encode it as a
code word right so fix some map that
Maps messages to code wordss and the
hope is that then if something bad
happens we're able to recover so
something bad happens in this picture
means that the code word gets perturbed
a little bit um so we're going to see
throughout this boot camp several
different definitions of bad things that
can happen um for my talk something bad
is going to refer to adversarial errors
so a bad guy an adversary picks some T
positions in the code word and gets to
uh munge up those positions or you know
get to edit those positions how however
they like um so in this picture here
that means that this code is going to be
per and this tells us why we care about
distance because if T the number of
Errors is less than half the distance we
can see that by the triangle inquality
can sort of round back at least in
principle to that code word and so the
goal will then be step three to decode
and recover the original message even
though there was a little bit of error
so these this is sort of the main
algorithmic task that we're going to be
focusing on is how the heck do we do
this decoding algorithm
efficiently great and then there's one
other thing that I want to Define which
is the rate of the code um so the rate
of a code which I'll always to know
capital r is uh defined as the log of
the size of the code based the size of
the alphabet divided by n which is the
same as K Over N where K here is the
length of these messages so you should
think about this this is the message
length divided by the code word length
AKA like the number of bits you wanted
to send or store or whatever divided by
the number of bits that you actually
ended up sending or storing sorry ended
up bits symbols in um uh so this is a
number that's always between zero and
one we want it to be as close to one as
possible because that means we have as
little redundancy as
possible okay so this is all of my
terminology about coding theory in one
slide are there any questions
it's on the same
page fantastic cool okay so one more
piece of notation um so I'm going to be
talking about algebraic codes going be
talking about evaluation codes so just
some a framework for that uh we're going
to Define an evaluation code we need to
pick a collection of points which I'll
call Curly P of size n as well as a
collection of functions which I'll call
Curly F that match the points and curly
P to this alphabet sign um and then
these are going to Define an evaluation
code C which is basically all the code
words that look like this so you pick a
function f in curly F you evaluate it at
all of the points in curly p and that
gives you a vector you look at all these
vectors that gives you a vector okay uh
a classic example of evaluation codes
which is the one we're going to be
focusing on in this talk is read Solomon
codes um and so for read Solomon code
the alphabet is some just some finite
field fq curly P the set of points is uh
a set any set of n distinct points you
like in the field um and curly F uh the
functions are just all of the pols over
F2 of degree strictly less than K so
this is a code with Dimension K or
message length k and a block length n
code words just look like
this all right um so there are a lot
more examples of um evaluation codes uh
so here we said read Solomon codes which
you know curly p is any set of size n
curly f is polinomial of degree less
than k
um you could also Imagine for example
read M codes which is the multivariant
version or algebraic geometry codes
which some more exciting version that
I'll talk very briefly about in the
second talk um or multiplicity codes
where you also include derivative
information I'm going through these very
fast and not actually um saying what
they are but the point is just that
there's a lot of these um but we're
going to focus on read Solomon codes
because I think the algorithmic ideas
are sort of best explained um before we
sorry can I ask a question yes should I
think of there as being one code for
each choice of function in curly F or
the code is defined by the entire set of
curly F uh right yeah so the question is
is there a code for each function in
curly F or is the code defined by all of
curly F the code is defined by all of
curly F so I'm always evaluating on
every polom yeah so formally Here's the
the definition of this code um right so
it's a set right a code is just a set
and what are the items in the set
they're indexed by the functions F and
curly F and for each function f you get
a different code word so you can think
of about f as being like your message
and then a list of evaluations of f as
being the encoding of that message yeah
great question more questions at this
stage
great cool okay so uh we're focused on
read Solomon codes um everyone's cool
with what read Solomon codes are so
we're just evaluating uh low deegree
polinomial and writing down a list of
evaluations and then looking at the set
that that generates um right and so for
the the rest of talk one we're going to
see three examples of an algorithmic
Paradigm for decoding read Solomon codes
or the last one's going to be ped read
Solan codes which is kind of a rip on
read solivan codes um and these are uh
all and these are all examples of the
same Paradigm so I'll give the three
examples and then say the Paradigm
generally um so the the main point of
this first talk is sort of to really
Hammer home this new technique or might
not be new for some of you I know it's
not new for some of you um but uh to
remind you perhaps of this new technique
or to give put us all on the same page
of this technique um so I am going to go
through a few more of the details um and
yeah we'll see these sort of free nails
that we can apply this to um but there
will be more uh open problems so I'll
talk a little bit at the end about open
problems and there'll be a lot more in
the in the second part of the talk okay
so let's get started with our um first
uh example here unique decoding of read
selement codes um and the bur Camp Welch
algorithm oh which I have a sorry bur
Camp Welch
um okay so before we talk about what the
algorithm is uh let's try to formalize
what the problem is so we're trying to
do unique decoding for worst case errors
what does that mean right so let's see
the AR Solomon code we Justus Define so
uh it is the code words are uh given so
each code word corresponds to a function
f which is a LLY
polinomial um so the first thing I claim
is that the distance of this code C is n
minus k + 1 where n is the number of
evaluation points K is the bound on the
degree and plus one is plus one right so
why is this the case well let's just
look at two distinct code words in this
code right they're given by two
different pols f and g each of degree
less than K and we want to know in how
many points do these two differ but we
can sort of draw a picture like maybe F
looks something like that g looks
something like that and then we look at
that and say well okay how many places
are they the same at most K minus one
places because two polinomial of degree
at most K minus one agree and at most K
minus one
points um so these like cuy things that
I've drawn three at most three points um
and so that means that there's at least
n minus K plus one points of
disagreement which by the definition of
distance means that the distance is n
minus K plus one sense cool and um this
is optimal uh it it meets what's known
as the single in Bound so it turns out
that readed Solomon codes get the
optimal tradeoff between rate and
distance um which is one of the reasons
why like them so much um they're very
easy to Define and it's very easy to see
that they sort of optimally trade off
between these two parameters that we
care about so that's
fantastic cool okay so now let's think
about um what what we want to do with
these codes so now we know the distance
so we know that the the picture the
little cartoon looks like this all of
the points are separated by at least nus
k + 1
so that means that if an adversary
introduces less than half that number of
Errors we should be able to recover it
right so if the adversary introduces T
errors so on the one hand that means
that what we see is something like this
we see some function G evaluated on
these points alpha 1 through alpha n to
the points in p and this function G
doesn't necessarily have to be a low
degree polinomial it's just some
function but we're promised that it
degrees with f um our Target low degree
polinomial in all but T places and up
here the picture is like G is pretty
close to and by the triangle inequality
if we draw like a Hamming ball of radius
T around G that means that there's a f
is the unique code word that lies in
that Hamming ball so at least in
principle we should be able to recover
it and that is our goal given G recover
F we want to do that
efficiently um so this is the problem
does this make
sense great all right so let's is there
a question no cool so let's see how to
solve the problem um so we'll do this
with the bur Camp Welsh algorthm I
spelled correctly this time um so this
is a slightly non-standard presentation
so that it can lead a little more nicely
into the next thing but it's basically
the same algorithm um okay so I'll say
the algorithm kind of at a high level
with lots of holes in it and then we'll
go through the analysis and kind of
reverse engineer how to fill the
holes okay so uh here's our algorithm as
input we're going to take a function G
evaluated on these points Al one through
alpha n and p and we're promised that
there is some low degree polinomial so
some polinomial F degree less than K so
that g is close to F and hand distance
closer than half a distance and our goal
is to recover f um great so there's
going to be three steps to our algorithm
the first step is to interpolate a
polinomial q of XY so a byari polinomial
and this polinomial is going to have a
particular form so it's going to be
linear in y and some other degree in X
and we'll have to figure out what that
other degree is in a moment um and we're
going to interpolate it so that it
vanishes on points that look like Alpha
comma G of alpha for Alpha in curly P
where G is our our input
function okay uh and also this is should
be a non-zero polom obviously the zero
polinomial should do this I'm going to
forget to say nonzero repeatedly
whenever I say interpolate a polinomial
I mean a
non-zero um and uh so that's step one
step two which is not actually an
algorithmic step but sort of a step
that's useful for the analysis is to
assert that when I plug in F ofx for y I
get a polom that is identically
zero so I will do this assertion that's
step two and then step three is based on
that assertion I'm going to somehow
solve for f so this is the outline of
the
algorithm so there should be several
questions at this point um unless you've
seen this before uh but three natural
questions are okay why can we
interpolate this polinomial why does
such a Q exist and how do we find it
efficiently the second thing why is this
true why is it true that uh when we plug
in F for y we get a polinomial a unar
polinomial tically zero and then step
three okay how do we solve for um and
I'll I'll spoil it a little bit and tell
you the answers and these three
questions are going to appear for all of
our three examples and they're always
going to have the same answer so the
answer to question one is linear algebra
um right basically interpolating a
polinomial right you're setting up a
linear system your variables are the
coefficients of the polinomial you have
these constraints which are linear
constraints on the on the coefficients
so we're just going to count the number
of coefficients so count the number of
variables and count the number of
constraints and as long as the number of
variables is strictly more more than the
number of constraints that means we have
a non-trivial solution and we can find
it using our favorite linear algeb
techniques great okay so that that
that'll be the first question the second
one uh why is it true that this
univariate polinomial is identically
equal to zero the answer to that one is
going to be because low degree pols
don't have too many roots so our
strategy here is we're going to show
that this uh univariant polinomial on
the one hand has a bunch of roots but on
the other hand is relatively low degree
and we'll show that it has more Roots
than its degree and that means that it
must be identically zero right so that
that will answer that question and then
step three solve for f how do we do that
um by staring
um will be so in this example it really
is by staring we look at be like
obviously you sol breath it's this is
going to get harder and harder as we see
more examples so staring is kind of a
standin for look at it and do something
creative and pull something out of a hat
um but yeah staring is what I'm going to
write down okay um great so this is the
outline let's go through these steps um
in more detail now uh and we'll sort of
see what has to happen Okay so step one
the interpolation step so we're going to
interpolate this byari polinomial that
is linear in y and we want it to vanish
on uh all of these points and let's say
that a KN has degree D and A1 has degree
D1 and we need to figure out what a KN
and A1 are are going to
be okay um so like I already described
how we're going to do this we're going
to count the number of degrees of
freedom in this linear system and then
we're going to count the number of
constraints and show that we can get
more you know figure out what D1 and D
have to be to make that work so uh
number of coefficients right so how many
coefficients are there that I get to
choose for a polinomial of this
typ this is not a trick question it's
early in the morning I want some inter d
right yeah so I heard d0 plus D1 right
um or plus or minus one something like
that there's an extra one for the
constant term yeah so we have d0 plus
one for a not D D1 plus one for D1
great uh okay and how many constraints
do we have One Two
Three N very good okay this is fun all
right uh so we want the number of
coefficients to be strictly larger than
the number of constraints so set this
thing larger than that thing and solve
and we can say okay let's choose D KN to
be n minus D1 minus one that'll work
right so I'm going to replace D up there
with n minus D1 minus one and now
actually now I just have D1 and I don't
like doing subscripts in PowerPoint so
I'm just going to turn that into a d
okay so now we have this polinomial uh
and we know that A1 has degree D that we
still need to choose and a not has
degree nus D minus one great and as long
as we pick degrees like that we can do
step one we can interpolate that polom
so now let's move on to step two step
two is that this uh by variant
polinomial Q somehow explains F in the
sense that f is a root of it like when
you plug in F for one you get something
that's identically
zero okay um so again I already
explained but the idea is here low
degreee polinomial don't have too many
roots so let's let R be this Univar
polinomial that is what happens when we
plug in F for y so we get Q of X comma F
ofx and let's record how many roots
there are and what its degree is right
so how many roots does r ofx have at
least n n
why the the polinomial Q of XY vanishes
on Alpha d uh g g
oh wait oh nus t n minus t great yeah
yeah so right so let's sort of back this
out right so uh okay so the number of
roots of R ofx is the number of Alphas
so that g of alpha is equal to F of
alpha or it's at least that number right
because we interpolated Q to vanish when
we plug in Alpha comma G of alpha so if
G of alpha happens to be equal to F of
alpha then when we plug in Alpha common
F of alpha Q is also going to vanish so
we get root every time that g of alha is
equal F of alha and that's a lot because
the whole point was that g was close to
F so this is at least strictly greater
than nus T points because they disagreed
and strictly less than T points that was
our promise so we had at least n minus t
Roots fantastic okay and what is the
degree of R
ofx it's a little bit gross I'll just
write down what it is right it's the
maximum of these two terms either it's n
minus D minus one or it's D plus kus1
because when we plug in F for y we're
going to plug in a Kus de Pol so it's
the maximum of those two things so we
know that R ofx is going to be
identically equal to zero as long as the
number of roots is larger than its
degree right um so we need n minus t to
be at least this maximum right and we
can figure out what that should be uh
maybe I'll do it on the board here um
I won't be doing out very many
computations so let's just do it once
just to right so we want n minus t to
be greater than or equal
to Max of nus
gus1 K minus one uh okay so should
probably choose D to like equalize these
two terms um so let's n minus D minus1
is equal to D + K - 1
and I should have prepared because I
can't do math at the Whiteboard is D is
like n minus k over2 something like that
yeah okay and then that means that if we
choose D like that this thing is going
to
be n plus K over
plus minus
one like that I'm going to be a bit fast
and loose with the minus ones plus minus
ones and the floors and the ceilings and
whatever
um but okay so if we say that this is
the case then uh we solve for this and
we want T to be at most something like n
minus K over2 maybe with some plus or
minus ones maybe with some floors or
ceilings whatever right but if we if we
do that out we get uh yeah t should be
uh at least n minus K over2 or so um and
this is great yay because uh remember n
minus K or K plus one was the distance
and we want T to be less than half the
distance and that's exactly what we have
so Tada fantastic okay so step two we
can do as long as the adversary
introduces less than half the distance
of Errors um which is exactly what we
wanted but there's still one more step
step three we actually need to solve for
f so what do we know we have this uh
bivariate polinomial Q uh of the form
you know of this form so it's linear in
y um and we know that Q when we plug in
and F is identically equal to Zer so
that tells us that a plus A1 * f is
identically equal to Zer so how do we
solve for
Fus a z A1 yeah exactly we just solve
for f right so do polinomial division
and f of x is equal to minus a0 over A1
yay we've done it okay uh well so here's
the the algorithm again I'll just flash
it up are there questions about what
just
happened yes I do have one question uh
the expression got for f is really a
rational fun how do you know it's really
a polom in other words how do you know
that A1 divid a great yeah so the
question is uh like if I just do this
how do I know I actually get a
polinomial um well it's because I was
promised that this F exists right and so
I know that like I've like I I know that
this thing is true right and I know that
f is a low deegree polinomial and so
therefore like the thing that I get IS F
it's a low degree
polinomial more
questions um cool okay so how am I on
time okay great so uh cool so we've seen
example one oh yeah question can this
algorithm fail if so how can this
algorithm fail if so how so I just
proved to you that it works so what is
it like it can certainly fail if the uh
hypothesis aren't satisfied right so if
there is no F that's
close um yeah so actually maybe this
goes back to this other question if
there is no F that's close I can still
run this algorithm and I'll get
something but like maybe it'll be
rational function maybe it will be who
knows what but then I'll just I can
check that right I can look at this
polinomial or I mean it's not a
polinomial but I'll be like never mind
um and if it is a polom like I can check
and make sure it's close or
not um does that answer the question
great more
questions yes can you talk a little bit
about complexity analysis of the
Fantastic yeah so the the question was
about the complexity analysis which I
just kind of slipped under the rug so as
presented this is polinomial time right
uh
or reasonbly low Pol right so what do I
need to do I need to do some linear Al
that's like n cubed at worst um and then
uh asserting doesn't take any time at
all uh and then solving for f I need to
do polinomial division um so I think the
the dominating step is the linear
algebra um but the reason I'm not
talking too much about the complexity is
because so first you can optimize this
algorithm and do much better but there's
also there's actually much better
algorithm or much faster algorithms for
decoding rellan codes um so uh I think
the burant Massy algorithm and riffs on
that are actually much faster and they
can
be near like n log maybe with some log
log NS um uh and people have worked
really hard on optimizing the heck out
of those and this is this is not bad um
so yeah not yeah it's a good question
and I'll I'll have some references for
that later in the talk too yeah question
can how many bits the adversity changes
can that figure out into the running
time like can you make it sensitive to
the doesn't change and minus SC two bits
then great question yeah so the
adversary gets to change t- bits Which
is less than this but what if the
adversary chooses to only change one can
you make it faster um so again the bur
Camp Massie algorithm which is not this
algorithm uh you can and that's another
like so if if the adversary just changes
T bits then um actually you can do
syndrome decoding in in sublinear time
that that it depends on t uh rather than
um
um yeah maybe ask me later and we
can can this alith I guess the state
this algorithm
doesn't really get
any I don't see how to make it better if
you have less errors anybody
know could you itely
interpretate like change
D you can interpret with lower degree if
there's R
right uh oh I see if if you know that t
is smaller
yeah I guess maybe that makes your that
makes the system you're solving slightly
smaller yeah so
maybe yeah how can anyone come up with
this Q uh how can anyone come up with
this Q uh do you mean like the form of Q
or the this is the thing right that's a
great question yeah how how do you
decide that Q should be linear in why uh
so actually the original presentation of
the bur Camp Welch algorithm is a bit
different than this
um
so basically A1 is meant to be a standin
for like for the aor locator polinomial
so this you think of this as being a
polinomial that vanishes on all of the
errors and then you think of a not or
maybe negative a KN as being the
received word g
and or gtimes A1 or something uh yeah
maybe we could talk about it offline but
yeah this this is sort of a re fitted
version to make it lead into the next
part of the talk there is a much more
natural way to describe this algorithm
where there's more intuition for what
exactly a not one
are maybe in the interest of time
because I do have two more examples I
want to go through uh maybe we consider
consider that nail hammered and um move
on to uh list decoding these are all
really good questions um but maybe
they're pushing a little beyond the
scope of the talk um
okay cool so uh right so our our next
example is list decoding of read Solomon
codes this is the gorami Sudan algorithm
so we all know what read Solomon codes
are now I need to tell you what list
decoding is okay so what is list
decoding
so uh it like unique decoding it is a
problem that we can solve so um we're
going to have our read Solomon code C
and we already know the distance of C is
n minus K plus1 so the picture looks
like this but now let's say we're in a
parameter regime where the adversary
introduces too many errors more than
half the distance right uh so down here
what that means is that we're going to
get some function G that agrees with f
in all but T places but that now that
means it might disagree with f in like
kind of a lot of places and
geometrically in this picture that means
that g is going to be a little bit
further from F and in particular if we
draw a Hamming ball of radius T around g
f might not be the unique thing in that
Hamming ball anymore there might be more
things so our goal before was to recover
F but as we can see now at least you
know with worst case errors this is
impossible there might be multiple FS we
have no way of knowing which one was the
right one so instead we're going to
readjust our Ambitions and try to
recover a short list of possibilities
for and there are many different reasons
you might want to do this I'm not going
to talk about them right now although we
we'll see one application in the the
second half
of okay so this is the list decoding
problem are there questions about the
statement of the problem
cool okay so uh here is the G Swami
Sudan algorithm for solving this um so
actually for Simplicity I'm not going to
present the full gor Swami Sudan
algorithm I'm going to present a simpler
version known as Sudan's algorithm
sorry um but well I'll wave my hands at
the end for what makes it the
girl um yeah so uh right so as before it
has kind of the same form because the
whole point is that we're doing the same
formula again and again so we'll start
with a function G ofx evaluate all these
points that's our input and we have the
promise now that the difference between
or that that f is close to some lree
polinomial G but now close is T and what
is T for now let's make it TBD we want
it to be as large as possible let's go
through the algorithm and see what we
can get okay so our first step as before
is we're going to interpolate a
polinomial uh but now instead of being
linear in y it's going to be degree Dy
in y otherwise it's an arbitrary Pol and
it's still going to vanish on these same
points that we had it vanish
on step two is exactly the same we will
assert that this thing Q of X comma f
ofx is identically equal to zero and
step three is that we're going to solve
for a short list of possible FS right so
the things that are different from
before are in Red so the thing that's
different is that now this is going to
have higher degree in y and we want to
return a short list of possible FS
instead of all the
s and usual we have the these same three
questions why can we interpolate that
polinomial why is it true that this
Univar polinomial is identically equal
to zero and how do we find a short list
of possible SS and my answers are going
to be exactly the same linear algebra
low deegree polinomial don't have too
many roots and staring so let's go
through these three steps and dig a
little bit more into these questions
okay so step one interpolation step we
want to interpolate the polom of this
form that vanishes on these points okay
uh and let say that um these pols a A1
up through ay have degree DX so this is
sort of a generic polinomial that has
degree DX and d and Dy and
Y and we need to figure out what DX and
Dy should be in order to make all this
St so let's do the same exercise we did
last time we need to count the number of
coefficients the number of constraints
and we need to choose DX so that the
number of coefficients is strictly
larger than the number of constraints so
that we can find a non-al solution to
this linear system okay how many
coefficients are
there DX plus 1 Dy great DX plus 1 time
Dy + 1 that's the number of of monomials
that you that you get to pick
coefficient for how many constraints are
there one two three and good all right
um we're losing enthusiasm come on
guys I guess it's because there's no
coffee allowed in the auditorium I
understand all right um so how do we
choose DX okay we want number of Co
efficients to be strictly larger the
number of constraints so solve for DX
let's take DX to be n over Dy + 1 and
that'll do it right so I'll replace DX
up there with n over Dy + 1 and once
again I don't like doing subscripts in
PowerPoint so now we only have one Dy so
that's going to turn into a
d okay so now we have this polinomial uh
has degree D in y and degree n D+ one in
X and we can move on to the next step so
next step is we want to say that Q
somehow explains F in the sense that
when we plug in F for y we get something
that's
Z so we'll do the same thing as before
so let R ofx be this univariate
polinomial that happens when we plug in
F for y and let's count roots and uh
compute the
degree so this is exactly the same as
before the number of roots of R ofx is
the number of Alphas at least the number
of Alphas that g of alpha is equal to F
of alpha um for exactly the same reason
as before and for exactly the same
reason before that's at least uh n minus
t so that bit is exactly the same as the
first time and what's the degree of R
ofx uh okay we can just sort of the
degree is going to be dominated by this
term we plug in a degree K minus one
polinomial here uh so that's going to
give us n D+ one for um the a term and d
k plus one for the FX
to cool okay uh so now we just want to
solve for the D that we need so that the
number of roots is larger than the
number of degrees as larger than the
degree because that will mean that the
thing is identically equal to zero um
how do we do that well once again let's
choose D to like equalize those two
terms I'm not going to do it on the
board I just did it for you uh we should
um turns out we should choose D actually
yeah so first let me be fast and loose
about the plus minus ones because
because I am um and so this is like
let's call this n/ D plus d * K and then
we want to balance these two terms to
kind of make this as small as possible
so let's choose D to be the square root
of n over K and we see that this degree
is going to be about 2 * root n k and if
we choose things like that move that up
there then okay we want to solve for D
so that this is larger than that or
sorry but we want to see what T needs to
be so that this is larger than that and
uh we see that we need T to be at most
nus 2 * theun n
k yay maybe uh not sure um okay sorry
this this is a bunch of math the algebra
doesn't matter um but does the the
outline make
sense cool okay so we'll come back to
whether or not this bound on T is is
good or not in a moment um but let's
finish up the algorithm first by doing
step three solving for f so what do we
know uh we know that we have this uh
bivariant polinomial um Q of XY of
degree D in y and we know that when we
plug in F for y we get something
identically equal to zero which means
that this is the case uh so how many
possibilities are there for f and how
could we find
them yeah so if we if we just ignore the
X's here right this is just a a
polinomial in F of degree D so we can
there should be at most D roots of this
polom uh and we can find them
efficiently and it turns out that the
fact that these are pols rather than
just field elements doesn't really
matter this the same thing still goes
through so that that intuition works out
and it turns out that we can do some
algebra and solve for the atmost D roots
of this polinomial and remember D was we
had chosen to be like root n k which um
k n is the rate of theode that's R so
this isun one R so get constant rate
code this is like a a constant number of
possible
solutions okay uh questions at this
point so what just happened we we walked
through these three steps and we saw
that as long as T is less than something
then there's at most a constant number
of choices for f and we can find them
efficiently um but is that good what
what is this bound on T actually mean
right so we said that t has to be at
most nus 2 * the of NK and it turns out
you can actually drop that to um this is
going from the Sudan algorithm to the
guruswami Sudan algorithm and there's
basically two techniques that one needs
to do to do that one we can be a bit
more clever about assigning degrees to
the AI I chose them all to have the same
degree that was pretty wasteful and the
other thing is um we can introduce
multiplicities so we can ask you to
vanish with higher multiplicities I'm
not going to go into it um you can see
uh paper from G
again um and uh yeah but so so this is
the the bound that we get we're still
wondering is that good
so we factor out an N here n minus root
n k this looks like n * 1 minus the root
R where R is the rate of the code so uh
turns out that this is something called
the Johnson bound and some combinatorial
bound um but I'm going to skip over that
for time um and the the point is that
this does seem pretty good like when R
is small this approach is n and that can
be way bigger than half of the distance
which approaches n/ two as R gets small
um so it's like twice as big uh that's
pretty awesome but it turns out we could
hope to do better there's something
called the listic coding capacity
theorem that uh says that actually the
best you could do is not n * 1 minus
root R but instead n * 1 minus r and r
is between zero and one so R is smaller
than root R this is better right so we
could hope to do to do better and we
want to and that's what we're going to
do in our next example um so before I
move on to the next example are there
any quick questions about this
example yes isn't the Baseline always
just like evaluating it and then
Computing the distance metric with
respect to all of the potential code
words so like why why is there even any
bound on T at
all uh oh I see
um so let me see if I got your question
right so you're saying suppose I don't
care about efficiency yeah instead I
could look at all of the code words and
see uh how like just pick out all of
them that happen to be in this bound
yeah you just accept Project based on
within T yeah so you're absolutely right
that is an exponential time algorithm to
solve this problem um maybe I was a bit
fast and loose with my definition of
list decoding earlier so when we say
that a code is list decodable uh what we
mean is that actually the number of
those code words is subexponential is is
bounded by something non-trivial right
so when T gets too large it could
possibly be that actually there's an
exponential number of code wordss in
that ball and so then we'd have like an
output of exponential size and there's
no hope of having an efficient algorithm
um but uh if we if we know that there's
a small number of code words in that
ball then we could hope for having an
efficient algorithm and actually there's
a distinction between combinatorial list
decoding which is can you just prove
that there's a constant number of cod
wordss in that ball and algorithmic list
decoding which is find them efficiently
um actually for readed Solomon codes
this is a big open problem there are yes
so open problem I don't have my little
graphic here uh we know uh advertisement
for Jonathan's talk that combinator some
read Solon codes are list decodable all
the way up to to this bound so we know
that there aren't too many Cod words in
this ball we have no idea how to find
them efficiently um
yeah if you have number how do you know
which is the correct one
chose yeah great question yeah so the
question is like essentially what is the
point of list decoding I want one answer
you're giving me a constant number of
answers I still want one answer um yeah
and so uh I hav several answers to that
question so one we'll see in the second
talk actually how you can use this to do
unique to coding um but also it turns
out that list decoding is actually just
a very useful combinatorial and
algorithmic primitive even Beyond coding
Theory so it has applications in for
example complexity Theory and algorithm
design and things like that um so maybe
we can talk more offline about other
yeah when we talk about efficient
algorithms is efficient on what like
like there's a number of uh of solutions
or like elements that you're L coding
also part of this PO this efficiency or
not
uh yeah so the question is what's the
definition of efficiency and is the
number of these code words part of that
definition yeah yeah so the number of
code words has to be part of that
definition because I should output all
of them and it takes at least time all
of them to Output them uh that give me
the I one and then you you uh okay
that's true yeah
um yeah that I could hope to have some
canonical ordering and say give me the
i1 that's right or actually we'll see
won't see given in time but uh there are
algorithms that
could produce a description of a
Subspace that contains all of these
things which would go a little bit
faster um yeah so right now I guess what
I'm talking about is the time it takes
to return all of them and what by I mean
by efficient in this talk is polinomial
time and N um but you're absolutely
right you could definitely think about
other definitions that Mak
sense yeah list to coding capacity of
that as a b is that
something that's as good as we can do is
from combinator point of view or Al a
CLA about efficiency yeah great question
so yeah so this list to coding capacity
this is a combinatorial statement um so
if you uh take t a little bit larger
than that then there will be an
exponential number of code words in that
fall so there's no efficient algorithm
to return them all great
minutes minutes Oh I thought I had four
so I'll take 10 ah all right 10 minutes
well in that case I might even be able
to do the third example
all right cool so uh let's um maybe we
can table further questions are there
any clarifying questions um these are
all really good questions but I want to
get through the last
example people have some sense of what's
going on cool all right so let's
consider that nail hammer and we'll move
on to the the last one that I wanted to
talk about which is uh listic coding of
folded read Solomon codes and this is
going to get us all the way up to that
list coding capacity thing so we'll be
able to take T larger than n * 1 minus
root R we'll be able to take it all the
way up to T * 1us but first I need to
Define what folded read Solomon codes
are there are a slight tweak on read
Soloman codes okay so to get folded read
Solomon codes these are introduced by
gami and rudra basically you start with
the read Solomon code um and I'm picking
the evaluation points not to be an
arbitrary alpha 1 through alpha n I'm
now picking them to be gamma gamma squar
gamma cubed gamma fourth dot dot up to
gamma the N where gamma is a generator
of mulative group of the field so as you
power up gamma you're going to go
through all of the element of the field
just in order and then what I'm going to
do is I'm going to take this code word
and I am going to sort of literally fold
it like this um so I'll take the first s
symbols and just write them down like
that and the second s symbols write them
down like that and so on and what I've
done by doing this is I haven't really
changed the information that I'm
presenting but i' I've changed how it's
packaged so I'm going to view this
original read element code word as a
code word in a code with alphabet F of
length n and after I fold it I'm going
to view this as a code word in a code
over alphabet F to the S of length n
/s so I've made the alphabet size bigger
and you might ask what does that get me
like why should that help at all and
intuitively this is kind of restricting
what the adversary can do before let's
say the adversary was allowed to corrupt
a a tow fraction of the symbols they
could choose that to fraction however
they wanted distrib among any of the now
they're kind of constrained that like if
they want to corrupt this one well they
may as well corrupt all of these others
but they can't correct like any old to
fraction of the original symbols anymore
so this kind of constrains the adversary
so this does make our problem a little
bit
easier uh great and this is going to
give us the folded read Solin code of
length and a rest just made up of all
the all the sort of folded versions of
the code words of the is a definition
clear
yeah okay so uh let's see if I can I'm
going to have to speed a little bit
through this algorithm so I will wave my
hands about some of the details but I
I'll try to get through the the parts
that matter that we'll build on for the
next talk okay so here's the algorithm
um this is due to to G Swami and Wang in
2015 um it looks a lot like the
algorithms we've already seen no
surprise that's the point um so as input
we have our function G evaluated on P
and we're promised that g is T close to
some low degree polinomial F but now
distance is measured in this kind of
like folded Hamming distance way so on
on these Mega symbols the degrees on all
but
T and T is going to be what we wanted to
be is going to be about the block length
which is n / s * 1 minus r and that's as
large as it can be according to the
listic coding capacity that I mentioned
earlier so that that's the punch line
cool stuff so what are we going to do
we're going to interpolate a polinomial
uh but now it's not going to be byari
anymore it's going to be R plus one
variate for some param r that we need to
choose and it's going to have variables
y1 through y r and our the form of our
polinomial is it's going to be linear in
the Y's and have some degree in the X's
that we'll need to choose second step is
exactly the same um oh whoops no Second
Step ought not be the same that error uh
we're going to assert that Q of X comma
F ofx comma F of gamma X comma F of
gamma s x comma dot dot comma F of gamma
to the r minus One X so when you plug in
F and then F of gamma X and so on and
for the various y's we're going to
assert that that is identically zero
sorry for the title uh and then we're
going to solve for a short list of
possible apps and we have our same three
questions as usual why do we interpolate
that but how can we interpolate that
polinomial why is it true that this
thing identically is zero and how do we
solve for a short listed possible s and
same answers as before linear algebra
low degree polins don't have too many
roots and staring so in the fiveish
minutes that I have
let uh let's let's walk through these
steps real real quick okay so first step
interpolation step uh I'm going to skip
this because this is exactly what you
expect we just count the number of
coefficients we count the number of
constraints H oh I actually need to say
what the constraints are
um you know what for the of time we're
gonna yes I wrote down what this should
do this should vanish on Alpha comma G G
of alpha comma G of gamma Alpha do all
way to G of gamma Rus one alpha or some
set of Alphas um basically the idea is
we're gonna want this to vanish sort of
on these R Points and then we're going
to slide the window down and ask it to
vanish on those ones and slide it down
again Ask it to vanish on those ones and
so on this is going to give us a whole
bunch of constraints um but I think in
the interest of time you know you can
ask me later or read the paper for the
details
uh but we can do out a bunch of maths
and um that was St two
sorry um it turns out that if
we uh choose D to be roughly like that
then you can interpretate this polomia
and I I know that I'm not fully
explaining exactly what are the
constraints but you can ask me later
it's not that important okay and then
step two uh assert that sorry again this
is typo Q of X comma F ofx comma F of
gamma X comma do dot comma F of gamma to
the Rus one of X is identically equal to
zero um once again this is exactly the
same uh
calculation we count the number of
points of agreement we count the degree
and we show that the number of roots is
strictly larger than the degree um so
I'm just going to flash through this
because I don't think doing up the
arithmetic is very enlightening um but
okay we get turns out something like
this that t is at most n / stimes 1
minus some stuff and remember what we
wanted was t s * 1 minus r and so if we
stare at this and we're like well let's
take R to be real big like a big
constant let's take s to be like a
bigger constant then this is pretty
close to n/ S * 1us R and so that that
tells us how how we're going to choose
these parameters R and S so s remember
that was like our folding parameter
that's how big the alphabet needs to be
and R was uh doesn't really matter some
parameter in the algorithm that I just
skipped fine but the point is we can
make this approximately right yay okay
um and here's the step that I actually
want to dwell a little bit on which is
solving for f right so what do we have
so far we have this polinomial of this
particular form and we know that when we
plug in oh sorry so many typs it should
be an R minus one uh when we plug in
these FS we get something that's
identically zero and so what does that
mean that means that uh this thing is
identically zero and we somehow want to
pull F out of this right and this
requires I think a little more creative
staring than the previous ones um how do
we do it uh so I only have two minutes
I'm not going to explain how to do it in
a lot of detail but basically the idea
is this let's ask ourselves what is the
constant coefficient of this polinomial
so on the one hand it's zero because the
polom is identically equal to zero on
the other hand okay the constant
coefficient in each of these terms is
given by F times the constant
coefficient of
AI so this gives us some linear equation
for the F notot the constant coefficient
F in terms of the coefficients of f AI
which we have already interpolated so we
could hope to solve for
f so now imagine we've done that imagine
we know what f is now let's have ask
ourselves what is the uh what is the
coefficient on X in this polinomial the
linear coefficient well on the one hand
it's zero because the polinomial is
identically equal to zero but on the
other hand well okay at least in each of
these sums this is what's the
coefficient on X well it's the
coefficient on X on this guy times the
constant coefficient there we already
know what the constant coefficient there
is so great uh
plus the constant coefficient on this
guy times the linear coefficient there
we already knew the constant coefficient
of f the only thing that's unknown is
the linear coefficient we now have a
linear equation for that coefficient
let's solve for it and you can go on in
this way and you end up getting this
triangular system of linear equations
and you'll solve for F1 and then use
that to solve for f sorry solve for f
not use that to solve for F1 use that to
solve for F2 and so on right and then we
can solve for f
hooray um in one minute what am I what
am I being fast and loose about I just
told you how to solve uniquely for f
yeah Nick why aren there why are there
only a small number of FS
that yeah that's right like or there
should be unique solution in some sense
yeah like the thing I just described
should return a unique solution we know
that that's too good to be true so like
obviously this linear system isn't going
to be full rank like I can't actually
just solve for fnot it might involve
dividing by zero I can't actually solve
for F1 it might involve dividing by zero
um but actually by St by like writing
out this big linear system at St staring
at it you can sort of see that oh
actually the number of times that I have
to like the number of degrees of freedom
here is actually bounded uh I'm not
going to I have it on the slide but it's
a big mess of MTH so I'm not going to do
that um but the the the pun the key here
that I want to emphasize is that what
you can do by staring and then doing
some linear algebra is you actually get
a description of a low-dimensional
Subspace in this case it's going to be R
dimensional where R is this parameter
it's less than S that we chose so some
constant dimensional Subspace
that contains the list so you're going
to try to solve this system there'll be
some degrees of freedom and that's fine
that gives you a linear Subspace that
contains the list um and and that that's
sort of the the thing I wanted to
emphasize
um okay so let me wrap up because my C's
looking at me um so what have we learned
um yeah so we've seen this this basic
Paradigm so yeah I hope I've like really
tried to hammer home this technique um
no um you see this basic paradigm where
we are given as input some evaluation
some function G evaluated at our points
we know it's pretty close to F we want
to interpolate a pol and like we have
these three steps interpolate a
polinomial to vanish on some nice places
assert that when we plug in F in some
way we get something that's identically
zero and then solve for f for possibly a
short list of possible FS we had these
three questions and we always had the
same three answers great um uh I want to
mention a few open directions actually
some of which y'all already mentioned um
like how do we guess the form of this CU
it seems to require a lot of divine
inspiration um like maybe there's some
other cues that we could guess that that
could do better and I guess I also Me
Maybe Al the second one to mention this
the third one can we do something other
than low deegree polinomial don't have
too many roots for step two most pols
like if you take a random polinomial
over fq in expectation it has one root
um no matter what its degree is so like
maybe if we gave ourselves a little more
freedom and like random how we picked it
maybe we could do that step a little bit
better I don't know I haven't been able
to get that off the ground but
that yeah we could imagine um tweaking
various different aspects of this
Paradigm um right there are uh open
questions about the actual punch lines
but I think all y'all have already
highlighted those so maybe I will skip
that yeah go to Jonathan's talk to one
about uh read open questions regarding
read Solomon codes and someone else
asked about faster decoding algorithms
um yes that is an open question uh
although for Unique decoding of reel and
codes um has been very well okay so I'm
out of time so I will stop and you can
ask me probably don't have time for
questions yeah probably ask ask me
during the break if you have questions
in the meantime sign up give speed talks
and I'll see you after the
[Applause]
break
cryst